JD Vance just came out and said
one of the reasons people aren't having kids as much as they used to
is because of car seat regulation.
That is the craziest, most delusional thing I've ever heard in my life.
I've never had a conversation with one of my friends
who was on the fence about having kids
and been like, yeah,
you know, there's a lot of pros to having kids,
but the car seats. Like,
it's not funny, because he's completely missing any of,
like, the top reasons why the birth rate is declining
in order to, I don't know,
have a ridiculous sound bite.
This has to be on purpose
at this point, I can think of, like,
10 solid reasons just off the top of my head
of why the birth rate is declining.
Not anywhere in the top 10 nor top 50.
Is car seat regulation gonna be in there.
Yeah, we're just.
We're just making these kids too safe.
It's a pain in the ass. Nobody wants to do that.
I miss the good old days
when we used to strap them in the back of the car
with a cigarette in their mouth
and call it a day. You know,
the fucked up thing is they probably actually believe that.
Uh, helmets and car seats.
What a fucking riot. I miss the good old days
when you used to be able to beat your wife
and hang her kid out the window, like,
This would be funny if this was an SNL skit,
but, like,
the fact that this is
someone who wants to be the vice president of the United States,
it's shocking and horrifying.
Way to avoid the issues at all costs.